inflation expectation for the next
year's search to record high fox
business story okay
inflation for the next decline for
seventh straight month inmate to record
high according to a new survey from the
federal reserve bank of new york median
one year ahead of inflation expectation
last month rose
point six percentage points to four
percent the highest since the new york
fed survey of consumer expectations
began
inflation expectation over the short
term have in recent months been
increasing at a faster pace than a
medium term the four percent point
difference between the two is the
biggest spread on record respondents
also expect prices
for all commodities to increase over the
next year the median year ahead expect
expected change in food prices increased
2.2 percent
points to record height of eight percent
while the other year ahead expect change
the prices gas rose point six percent
points to nine
point eight percent my prediction i've
been saying that kai we got to make a
note for me to do that video on gas
prices
i predict gas prices in the next 12 to
24 months to it five to ten dollars
i was at it out of town a couple weeks
ago and i saw the gas prices
in california being at the uh uh what do
you call it uh no no no
premium was 489 is what it was regular
was 440.
today yesterday i was running out of gas
on my way to tsa building here in
what do you call it in florida by the
port barely found a gas station thank
god i did
270 260 what i'm paying for pathetic how
cheap the gas is over here compared to
but floridians are saying the gas prices
have come up i'm like this is nothing
compared to what it is inflation is
coming let me add that
with the other story together let me add
that with the other story together and
then i'm going to come to you guys for
your feedback
global tax rate could drive businesses
away from the u.s
watchdog warns also business fox
business story
president biden leaders of g7 group
nations endorse the global minimum
corporate tax rate of at least 15
percent of policy that could ultimately
drive business investments
away from the us that's according to
taxpayer protection alliance a
non-profit advocacy group based in dc
which argues that a higher global
minimum rate would ultimately be passed
on to workers and consumers through
reduced compensation
and higher prices there's some evidence
to suggest that corporate taxes
are ultimately borne by workers and
consumers a recent analysis conducted by
the tax foundation suggested that up to
of the tax burden falls into labor as
the tax reduces
as the tax reduces investment
productivity and wages the dollar amount
of costs and labor may exceed the
revenue raised by the tax
by wide margin the tax foundation said
but the biden administration has argued
a minimum tax rate
will build a more equitable tax system
that will help deliver a foreign policy
for the middle class and it will help
support working families everywhere
thoughts on inflation and the tax rate
increasing globally i i can just speak
from one perspective
inflation is in the news every single
day isn't inflation a horrible thing
that we should be afraid of
terrible okay for middle american low
income terrible thing yeah and they keep
talking about it like um there's a cold
front coming and temperatures might be
like
three percent colder during march
through april they're making it seem
like it's a
like just a little small little
ticky-tack little inconvenience
i mean if this hits like every jamie
dimon's talking about how
jb morgan is throwing away as much cash
as they possibly can because
the inflation is coming in a huge way
i'm scared as hell about it
you know i really am i mean how i know
what gas prices are because i pay them
in california you can see
other things inching up and you combine
that with the global shipping issues
that we have
and all the other things that are that
are in this pot and they're brewing
and it's going to be a very very
challenging time
coming for us very shortly so
we we talked about two topics right
there the the inflation and multitasking
yes i mean the one thing that comes to
mind here is what i just kind of
showed you over here with my little uh
venn diagram
there's things that you can control and
there's things that matter and
where they coalesce in the middle is
where you should focus you're not going
to stop inflation
bob sue joe mary it's going to happen it
is what it is the only thing you control
is what's going on
in the four walls under your house so if
inflation is four percent in this coming
year
or if it's transitory and it will be
closer to two percent
historically inflation is what two to
three percent annually
anyway over time so inflation going
gonna happen
there's nothing you can do to control it
and unless you're some
corporate tax avenger who actually has a
stance of what can happen at the
corporate tax rate
uh there's nothing you could do about it
so there's nothing you can do about
inflation
there's nothing you can do about the
global corporate tax rate the one thing
you can do
is focus on your own personal finance
and what i always say
save that money and then if you're
worried about inflation and you're
worried about
your dollar not being as powerful as it
is now
then start investing in assets that um
provide a better rate of return or start
investing in assets that
always talks about keyboard let me ask
you this
how's the middle class going to invest
in any of that with inflation going
up they're looking to afford milk in gas
you're right insurance
you're right you're right by the way
you're absolutely right so here's here's
the issue
did you see the story about blackrock by
the way luis rodriguez from
ecuador if you can text us at
310-340-132
i put the number down there luis text us
ecuador three one zero three four zero
one one three two i want to give you a
minute to share with us
how inflation affected ecuador so did
you see the story about blackrock going
and buying
homes from people and paying 25
about market rate did you see that
number of that story there no i didn't
say that
it's not in here it's not in here it's a
story so they're going around and
they're buying
real estate portfolios and they're
saying listen half a million dollar home
will pay 600 grand 400 000 home will pay
500 000.
they're overpaying for homes so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]